we're not having this baby
like your ears about to take off I'm
opening at The Improv on a Friday night
in Ontario I had a buddy who asked me
Jerry Jerry
so who's the dude that got left what's
gonna set you was it you who was it
let's do it over here where was it it
was him
[ __ ] y'all artists before I head stuff
on right here all of y'all obviously was
one dude over here
and a girl was stalking it she couldn't
take it anymore right
[Music]
I don't know who it is but one of y'all
is a [ __ ] what are y'all some sidepiece
for sure you didn't know who didn't know
she was a side piece where y'all out it
must be you cuz you gotta look at your
face like
[Music]
trying to be cool yeah that must have
been that your baby mama yeah who that
was I do it she's just mad right I'm
home with joke here okay well you know
she still loves you that's what that was
right there she had to come ruin the
show with her [ __ ] she could take it
where was she at did she come running in
I just kid did she buy it that that's
serious [ __ ] she bought a ticket ticket
for one ticket for one ticket for one
thank you
she came in here like damn
the [ __ ] bought a ticket
that's not man she was yeah we should
have had a two-drink minimum on their
[ __ ] sure okay let me get the Tanqueray
and a coke we just she walking with a
[ __ ] you drinks
that's crazy
it is what it is right this gonna be a
fun drive home cuz what I like is like
she's scary just one right here cuz she
got a look on her face like oh we gonna
handle this later that drive home she
gonna be driving out even looking at the
road
so why was that [ __ ] at the show I'm
just curious just curious [ __ ]
why was she looking matter now [ __ ] the
road let's talk about this home
I don't know it's scary [ __ ] every dude
in the room right now looking around for
a side chick like textures [ __ ] my mom
still sick yeah where the [ __ ] is he
going
was he looking at his phone at all I
don't trust that [ __ ] at all
you'll be out he'll be outside like
[ __ ] like this you know I love you girl
[Laughter]
you should just leave like that'll be
dope if you just like went out there
backdoor
are you really gonna leave out leave
[ __ ] him you know what I'm saying
but she going right to him though Wow
that was I guess they're not gonna have
these chips anymore huh
[Applause]
that's all I wanted
I'm breaking up Sam please I'm ruining
them Lisa get some potato chips he ain't
[ __ ] girl you should leave give me that
drink from where she currently is she
you know she go I can't even continue
with my [ __ ] I need to know this is she
they gone thank you alright
what the [ __ ] really happened
now was baby mama taking care of the kid
tonight oh well yeah boy obviously not
cuz she came here looking for you she
left your kid is in the car she came
storming back your daddy ain't [ __ ] but
[Laughter]
why was she mad don't [ __ ] don't
act like you don't know why she was bad
if we be friends now we try to find out
what the [ __ ] going on I got you how
do you know [ __ ]
will await this one look ahead to check
is that so true this big in the player
you [ __ ] planted him who with a side
shake tonight I'm just curious you know
what I love to all the dudes in the room
right now or hug and they went there
it's so [ __ ] funny right now
this dude is fingering his girl he got
his arm wrapped tightly around her [ __ ]
all the dudes in the room like no like
don't know no attention to me I love
that baby it's not me girl
you know I love you I would never have a
side chick you my girl right now they
holding hands underneath the table every
all the dudes and sneaky [ __ ]
right now ladies when I started getting
on him and your man just touched you
he's a cheater he's a [ __ ] cheater
that [ __ ] he's guilty of [ __ ] this
[ __ ] guilty as [ __ ] right here
guilty this is the weirdest show I've
ever done in my [ __ ] life thanks to
this too
[Applause]